أنا شاب نسبيًا عندما
بدأت العمل في أمازون ،
وهذا شيء ساعدني
عندما كنت في العشرين من عمري عندما بدأت العمل في
أمازون وعمري الآن 24 عامًا ،
ولكن حتى كوني شابًا وفي حالة جيدة ،
كان لا يزال يتعين علي التأكد من أنني سأفعل
اعتني بنفسي عندما كنت أعمل ثلاث
نوبات لمدة 12 ساعة
بحلول نهاية الأسبوع ، كان جسدي قد
أصبح متعبًا ومتعبًا
عندما بدأت العمل هناك في
الشهر الأول ، فقد فقدت ما يقرب من 10
أرطال وكان علي أن أبدأ في تناول الطعام من قبل  العمل
خلال استراحة
الاستراحة الثانية والاستراحة الثالثة وبعد العمل
للحفاظ على وزني الحالي
أعتقد من كل الطاقة التي كنت
أنفقها من
القيام بهذه المهمة لفترة طويلة وكانت
هناك أوقات
شعرت فيها بالإجهاد الذي شعرت به  الضغط على
ركبتي قد تؤلمني أو قد تؤذي ساقي
أو قد يؤلم ظهري
بعد الحصول على ترقية وبعض
التغييرات في الأجور التي أجرتها أمازون ، أجني
الآن 23 ساعة لم أجني
هذه الأموال دائمًا
أه لذا فهي تساعد في تحمل بعض الضغط
اعتدت على عدم القدرة على القيام بذلك  يمكنك دفع الفواتير
بسهولة أكبر وليس مجرد الحصول على راتب مقابل الراتب ،
لذا فأنا أعمل في قسم الروبوتات ،
إنها غرفة كبيرة تبدو
وكأنها غرفة بحجم 300 رطل ، حيث
ستحمل الروبوتات الأشياء إليك ، فهي
تتيح للأشخاص العمل
بشكل أسرع ، لذا فإن هذه الروبوتات تشكل
كل شيء خطيرًا  التي يمكن أن تحملها يمكن أن تزن
800 رطل إلى ألف رطل ، لذا إذا أصابك أحدهم
فسيكون مثل التعرض
للسيارة ،
وظيفتي هي التأكد من عدم
إصابة الناس بالأذى وأن الناس يعرفون
كيفية القيام باستكشاف الأخطاء وإصلاحها الأساسية معهم
في  الأمازون
لدينا مقياس مرح يسمى توت
كل قطعة عمل تقوم بها في كل
مهمة فردية ، هناك دائمًا عملية احتيال
تقوم بمسح عنصر يتم
بيعه ، تقوم بمسح حزمة قمت
بها للتو
بمسح موقع مخزون
دائمًا  يقوم نظام الكمبيوتر بمسح
يعرف
كل فحص واحد قمت بإجرائه
عند إجراء أول مسح لك في اليوم ،
لذلك عندما تبدأ في العمل ،
فإنه يعرف متى تقوم بإجراء آخر فحص
قبل أن تبدأ في القيادة.
قل أن
وقت استراحتك هو من آخر فحص
لك عندما تغادر إلى أول فحص
لك عندما تعود إذا توقف المسح
إذا لم يكن لديك عذرًا ، فهذا
عذر جيد بما يكفي ، فأنت تعلم أنه
كان علي الذهاب للصلاة  الحمام الذي ذهبت إليه
لأخذ استراحتي
إذا لم يكن لديك عذر مثل
أنك تبدأ في تجميع
الوقت الذي لم تكن
تعمل فيه بشكل مباشر على الأقل كما يمكن تسجيله بواسطة
نظام الكمبيوتر
يتم تخصيص مبلغ محدد من
وقت لهذه المهام
إذا كنت بحاجة إلى الذهاب إلى الحمام ،
فستحصل على ثماني دقائق بما في ذلك
وقت المشي للذهاب إلى الحمام
قبل أن تبدأ الساعة في التكتك إذا كان
لديك يوم سيء
يمكن أن يؤدي إلى ركوب
[موسيقى]
وهو أكبر شيء  لقد أبقاني هناك ،
هناك الأشخاص الذين أعمل معهم بعد
فترة زمنية
كنت أعمل فيها لمدة ثلاثة أيام 12 ساعة كل
يوم في
الأسبوع ، وقد سمح لي الجمع بين عطلة نهاية الأسبوع لمدة أربعة أيام
ونظام الإجازة المرن نسبيًا
بالقيام بأشياء أخرى
تريد أن تفعل هناك لديك  مررت كثيرًا من
المرات التي عملت فيها مع أمازون حيث كنت
أرغب في ترك الأشخاص مروا بأيام
تحتاج فيها فقط إلى الذهاب إلى كشك الحمام
وربما تحتاج إلى البكاء قليلاً
وأنت تعلم أنك بحاجة للاختباء في الزاوية
في مكان ما مثل حيث لا يوجد
أشخاص آخرون ، تمامًا مثل
الاسترخاء والاسترخاء ، مر الكثير من الناس
بلحظات كهذه.